monsieur sidaoui bienvenu merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on vient de le
voir l'algérie qui organise cette
réunion est ce qu'on peut dire que
l'algérie revient un peu en devant et se
comporte en tant que médiateur
actuellement pour le conflit libyen oui
oui sur taboulé président la geria
jeetah bull a bien signalé et l'a dit
maintenant on va s'occuper de la libye
c'est une priorité pour l'algérie et
c'est fini la distance puisque avant
impôts avec bouteflika ce qui s'est
passé en algérie la révolution a éloigné
l'algérie de la question libye et c'est
logique puisque les six pays voisins de
la libye
le second et l'egypte à l'est l'algérie
et la tunisie à l'ouest et le niger et
le tchad au sud c'est logique qu'il soit
présent parce que la sécurité en libye
concerne leur propre sécurité
directement
rappelons le par exemple les deux
attentats en tunisie les armes sont
venues de la libye the theory ce
tunisien son temps ont été entraînés en
libye donc la situation libyenne
concerne tout d'abord des six pays
voisins de la libye c'est ce qu'a voulu
la diplomatie algérienne le dire la
réplique la conférence de berlin et
d'autres conférences en europe puisqu'il
s'agit d'un problème aussi maghrébins
alors que l'algérie bénéficie bien
évidemment de cette position de deux
voisins que vous avez bien rappeler mais
aussi bénéficié également de puissance
militaire régionale on peut pas nier que
dans la région même sur le continent
l'algérie dans des pays
mieux dotées militairement oui il ya
deux grandes puissances l'original c'est
l'armée égyptienne pilar mais algérien
mais nous ne savons bien dans la
constitution algérien c'est interdit à
l'armée algérienne de combattre en
dehors du territoire algérien
ça veut dire l'algérien selon la
constitution ne peut pas aller en libye
alors l'égypte s'est totalement
impliquée dans le conflit en faveur
d'une armée nationale libyenne de rallye
va after qui domine actuellement presque
de trois quarts de la libye et il y à un
point de divergence si vous voulez
l'egypte et pour une victoire militaire
et stabiliser le pays par la force
militaire pas la victoire de l'armée
nationale alors que l'algérie la tunisie
ont choisi une autre option c'est le
dialogue entre les protagonistes libyens
afin de trouver une solution politique
pacifique et durable
donc les points de vue égyptiens et
algériens sont un peu différent
peut-être cette fois-ci ils vont se
rapprocher encore plus alors justement
en algérie donc plaidons pour une issue
une solution politique et refuse toute
ingérence dans ce conflit libyen je
parle bien évidemment de d'intervention
militaire
vu que l'algérie province un dialogue
inclusif est ce qu'elle voudrait
peut-être avoir les groupes armés autour
de la table des pourparlers en plus de
rallyes fin haftar est fayez elle
s'allonge oui l'algérie va ici l'algérie
a plus que 1000 km de frontière avec la
libye puisque 500 km la frontière entre
la tunisie la libye elle va ici et là
ici même en vendeuse trouver une
solution pacifique entre les
protagonistes libyens mais le problème
en libye sont nombreux médiatiquement
parlant nous connaissons bien failli
savage et le chef du gouvernement et à
l'ifa art
le maréchal raft le chef de l'armée
nationale libyenne est anobli par
exemple certaines qui sont des groupes
armés mais autonome on oublie tabou sud
en oublie même certains qui ne fait pas
cliqué aussi qu'elle aussi l'autonomie
militaire il ya plusieurs acteurs
acteurs militaires en libye le problème
aussi dans toutes ces conférences une
investigation ça passe souvent entre les
politiques
alors les politiques ne domine pas ne
maîtrise pas totalement la situation
militaire il ya des chefs de guerre
il ya des lits à des chefs de guerre
mêmes locaux qui sont enrichis à travers
cette guerre civile
et là il ya le clivage toujours entre le
politique et le militaire peut être un
jour si on arrive à réunir les chefs
militaires
enfin de la libye de la sainteté crise
peut être on trouve une solution durable
mais avec les politiques toujours on a
compris qu'ils ne peuvent pas obliger
les milices surtout à respecter des
soucis de feu monsieur acide et oui
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue et
directeur du quart apps le centre arabe
de recherche et d'analysé politique et
sociale merci d'avoir été avec tous